tai chi uh
is done in china and
they get up in the mornings if it's not
raining
it's just they meet in the park
it's hundreds and hundreds
of people gather and they just do their
own form or
you'll get people just
doing this
when you look in the park there's small
trees they bring their
their canaries and their birds in the
small cage and they
hang them in the trees and they just rub
against the trees
you know it's all about becoming
therapeutic and to them
it's their healthy routine of the day
the trees are
quite smooth and shiny where they've
been rubbing for years and years
against them with their backs their
bodies
okay so this is an exercise for people
if you have indigestion
stomach pains it's very good
my stomach is about here
i'm going to exaggerate i mean i've got
a bit of a tummy and i'm
working on it like many of us but i'm
going to just come
closer to the camera so that you can see
and i
push it out okay okay like a little
buddha
so my stomach area
here i'm pushing it out my stomach
area is here my stomach
area is here
okay no longer a six-pack
so i'm gonna just frame this
quite close to the camera not so much
worried about
you seeing all of me it's uh
important that you see the parts you
need to see
you can choose what hand you put on top
of the other
but if i put this hand on the top of my
stomach just it's it's at the top it's
not on the stomach it's
in that groove there's a groove that you
can find
around your body taking you around the
whole stomach
okay so because i've got this way
i'm going to go that way so i'm going to
be going
anti-clockwise i'm going to put this on
the top
and i'm going to just follow it down
and then obviously pull it back
come up follow it around
[Music]
down and i'm pressing quite hard
i can't obviously show you on film how
much i'm pressing
but if i try to show you if i push my
stomach out again
okay so
you know so you do need quite a good
pressure
but not to hurt yourself obviously so
you do this
once you get used to doing this
make sure you go right to the bottom
right around the edge
you can
do this with your body but it's not
necessary
what's necessary is that you cover full
circles
of your stomach and you must do it nine
times okay this goes
around nine times
once you've done the nine times
i haven't been counting so you have to
forgive me if you're counting this
at the end and say you didn't do nine
then you'll be right
but okay so nine times and then
stop change hands because i'm never
gonna go that way
put it on top so you've got a little bit
of pressure rather than this
sort of digging in you can keep them
flat with the pressure
so one
two three
four i'm not in a rush
five
six seven
eight
nine okay
and you should find that if you have
indigestion or
stomach hot pains or anything you should
find that that relieves it
it always has done me um i can't
guarantee
on everybody that's the thing we can't
do but i hope
that will help you and what i now feel i
feel a nice
tender sensitive area
but it's also but i also feel quite
nice okay
seven inch uh seven centimeters below
your
navel okay so i've got my thumb in my
navel
and i'm seven centimeters below
the palm of my hand just just here
right in the center you can do a little
push if you want
and i'm going to stand up more than hip
width apart
all the people apart and i'm going to
take that point in the hand
and i'm going to try to find
that that place i'm going to try to find
that place with my hand
now when will i know that it's there
when you feel that
if we had a pencil with a rubber on the
end
you'd feel that type of pressure as if
you was pushing
a pencil with a rubber on it okay
so you you search around
small circles you know where the area is
so you know where to search
and ah i found it so you can go in and
out
in and out
so what do you do with it now
well you can push from your
spot in your body to your hand
so concentrate on pushing out to your
hand
and you should feel the energy in your
hand increasing
in your hand push it in your hand
take both hands try it's in this hand
we've been putting it so this hand now
needs to receive it so what you're going
to do is you're going to move your hands
like this
but try to
feel it what it'll possibly do now is
it'll possibly go
from this point to your fingertips
tingling
okay don't worry about that allow that
to happen
once you get that connection you can
start doing it this way
you see you can stir it
and stir it and stir it and you should
now
when they're wider apart you should feel
this place
here stronger than the other one but you
should feel it in the other one
okay so you can try in and out
like concertinas or turning
some of you may think this is very basic
if you've been doing tai chi a long time
ago well i can do that that's
that's simple but i'm trying to go
from the ground upwards and
i'm trying to look at the fitness angle
as well as the
spiritual side if you like the feeling
of
spiritual feeling that you feel within
yourself
within your hands you know
you know after we've done the opening
form
and the hands come up and they hold a
ball
you know this is a feeling you should
have straight away
you know you turn the ball
and you turn the ball while you're
looking
like blankly it's actually you're
looking out
but you're feeling you're feeling
you're sensing you're sensing
okay so
we need the energy so that when you
push out to something like this
the power is coming here
it was a fighting skill but you don't
have to use it as a fighting skill
that's up to you as a human being if
you're you know if you're
a person that likes abruptness and
uh confrontation you might you know
you might want to do it like that i i
don't
um but you know the power is in there
and you make
mass you create mass you know how to to
move it you know
and the older masters they do it slowly
but they've still got the
the mouse so this hand and this hand
they're both
feeling now in this point
okay so we will build this
and we will build slowly please try
it's a very long path but it's hopefully
an enjoyable one
and if you've only done the stomach and
you only
done the energy
connect with the energy and then you do
this
and you play around with that then
you achieved a lot you know okay until
we
see each other again